hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be continuing our series on the middle
game strategies and we're going to do
with two part series here and we're
going to go over the key concept of
trading a lot of chess players really
don't know when they should be trading
especially during the middle game when
things are flying everywhere
they just don't know if a trade is good
a trade is bad and so today we're going
to be going over when you should trade
them when you shouldn't trade and so
we're going to four key concepts that I
want you to remember the first one is
you should trade when you're ahead and
material and that's what we're going to
be going over in part 1 the second is
you should trade if you have a spatial
disadvantage and we'll be going over
what that means you should also trade if
you if your exchange will make one of
your pieces really strong so if you can
trade and get like a great outpost for
one of your pieces you should do that
and lastly if one of your opponent's
pieces is really strong you should
obviously trade that off as well so if
we can go ahead and take a look at this
board here obviously this board white
and black are both even we can start off
let's say we take one of the pawns away
from black now White has a one pawn
advantage and that may not seem like a
lot but if we start trading off pieces
let's say we trade off the rooks here
White's advantage is getting bigger okay
and we can see that let's say we trade
off both of these knights and bishops
in a trade obviously I'm just deleting
them here but in the game you would you
would obviously just trade them off you
may not be able to see it but white is
getting a bigger and bigger advantage
and let's say we trade off our Queens
and the rest of our minor pieces so I'll
go ahead and take those off the board
here we'll just be left with the pawns
and you'll look at it and see that white
has all eight of its pawns - black 7
ponds and as we're taking these pieces
off White's advantage is growing and
growing
before we had
you know we have 16 pieces in black
started out with 15 and now we have nine
pieces and black only has eight and if
we start to take away some of let's say
we start taking off some of the pieces I
just took off five from each side now
black is left with two and white is left
with three obviously a much bigger
advantage and all we're doing is trading
off one by one and as you can see it if
we do one more now White has a
two-to-one advantage two-to-one
advantage is obviously a much bigger and
then we can even go one step farther and
take away another pawn and now white is
clearly winning and it's it has a pawn
black has no pieces that the King whites
in very good shape here so if you have a
material advantage you should be trading
to reach an in game where your advantage
is greater so in part one of our series
that is what we're going to be going
over we're going to be going over if you
have an advantage of material what you
should do and what you should not do
because a lot of times you get to a
stage where you know you may be up a
pawn you may be up to pawns and you try
to get too fancy and it may work it may
not when you could just make things
simple and take away all the pieces and
what you'd be left with is a clear
advantage a lot of people don't even
look at that when really they should so
I'm going to go ahead and give you this
position right here and it's White's
move and think about just for a moment
if you want to pause it what White's
should do here so take a minute pause
think will what you do
and if you look at it here white is up
upon and it may not look like white has
a distinct advantage but in actuality
they do whites best move here is white
captures this knight on c6 and yes you
would you could look at it and say well
white's bishop is good because it's an
open game bishops are obviously better
in open games and that's true
but in this case we can easily get to an
in game where we have a huge advantage
so since we're up a pawn
this piece is going to allow us to
quickly get to an in game where we know
we can win
so from here black is forced to take
with his pawn and now white can use all
of his pieces to sacrifice all the
pieces except the pawn so white can just
come here with his rook black is forced
to take with his rook white can
recapture on d8 black is forced to
capture with his rook white can come
with his Queen to d8 obviously as you
can see we're just trading pieces off
now black is forced to come to f8 and
now white can do the last piece and
we're traded off at f8 and here it's a
lot easier to see that white has an
advantage white has six pawns and black
has five pawns and a lot of people could
look at the position before and
completely miss the win and a lot of
times mess up and lose the game but here
we're going to go over why it's so
important if you're up in material to
trade down in later stages of the game
so from here it's a pretty clear win
we're going to go over how that's a
pretty clear win when you go from the
middle game going in towards the endgame
your King becomes your most valuable
piece obviously if you have Queens and
stuff those are but in a pawn and King
endgame you want to activate your King
and that's a very important concept in
any game so white wants to activate his
King as quickly as possible so
he may bring it to a to now black at the
same time they know this as well so he
may try to come to even and white can
continue and we can bring our peace to
d3 black can continue to d6 now from
here white can do a simple move of b4
with intentions of bringing his King to
the d4 square eventually what we want is
to tray off these pawns with one pawn on
the Queen side obviously the ABC squares
and distract the black King enough so
that we can come over here to the King
side and gobble up all these pawns and
have a clear advantage so let's say from
here I mean let's say Black has let's
say a subtle move of f6 he doesn't want
to to yet to commit anything so from
here we can bring our King into the
action obviously he can bring his pawn
to c5 but we have our nice little pawn
on b4 he can't bring his pawn to the a5
square because then we can just take
with our be pawn and march up the board
here so he might move his his Jeep on
here and from here we can continue to
march up the board with our with our a
pawn there's not a whole lot he can do
he may bring his pawn to the f5 Square
and from here we can create two
weaknesses we can go ahead and march
right up the middle with b5 and if he
wants to trade his pieces off let's say
he
let's say he just trades here and then
we trade and then he trades and then we
trade now we have a pawn here that the
black King has to do something about and
so let's say he comes back to the c7
square to protect we can come up here to
the c5 square and whenever time we've
won the black King has to defend if he
the black king moves off this C file to
the D file we can just march up the
board here make it Queen so the black
King is going to have to come to the B
file and once he does that white can
easily start marching his King to the
other side and start gobbling up these
pawns here so from here but I can come
he's obviously going to take this pawn
but he's not gonna have time to recover
we can come to the e6 square once he
takes obviously you can see the
advantage black can start to come he can
try to move his pawn it's not really
going to matter black King can continue
he can come down here try to get ours
there's nothing he can do we can start
marching up our H pawn it's a very clear
win for white and this all came about
because of our trading that we did when
we were ahead of material so even in a
position that looks almost even if you
have a material advantage and you can
get down to a very defined win as an
opponent King in game and you know how
to play a pawn and King in game
correctly it's a very straight forward
win so this is part one of trading and
how you should trade obviously keep what
number one is trade if you're a head of
material because it gives you a bigger
advantage so I hope this helps hope
they're in your game if you have an
advantage in material that you're always
looking out for ways that you can get
closer to the endgame
and I hope this helps bring you a lot
more wind so look out for part two
should be up shortly and I will see you
guys next time
thanks a lot